hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well in the third part of his proma to
any future metaphysics Emmanuel Kant has
a short but important section titled
General mark on the transcendental ideas
and this is sort of a bridge between the
main body of part three and the
conclusion the determination of the
bounds of pure reason that follows it
and it introduces some important topics
that will be taken up a bit more in the
next section so K is going to begin this
with a very interesting contrast one
that might be a little bit
counterintuitive but makes sense as we
explore it so he talks about our
understanding our
investigation into nature or our
experience and it tells us two things so
the first is about specific objects he
says the objects which are given us by
experience are in many respects
inconceivable right now we have to be a
little bit careful with that term
term literally it is the right
translation of
un unable to be
conceptualized we could say or if you
want to get closer to the root of it
unable to be grasp to be comprehended it
doesn't mean that we don't have any
notion of them whatsoever it just means
we can't get to the fullness of the
explanation that we would want of them
and then he goes on and says there's
many questions which the law of nature
leads us when carried Beyond a certain
point though still conformably to the
laws of nature that admit of no answer
and here he gives an example which has
to do with the physics of his time the
question as to why material objects
attract one another why does gravity not
only exist and work but do so in the
ways that we observe it to and can even
generalize about and so when we're
thinking about nature or experience as
such these things remain murky to us and
will remain so and you might say well
hey Kant we've made massive advances in
science yes true but we still have
questions and objects that were not
quite sure about and as we've gone
beyond what we might call straight out
experience to all sorts of extrapolated
experience it's gotten confusing as well
and what's the difference between this
and what we encounter when we go beyond
nature or exceed all possible experience
when we land ourselves in the realm of
mere
ideas um he says that we cannot say that
the object is inconceivable and that the
nature nature of thing proposes to us
insoluble problems now you would think
well if we can't even figure out nature
and experience how in the hell are we
going to figure out things that don't
have reference to that and are going
Beyond it that we're using reason to
understand are we is this like a
reflection of platonism you know there's
an intelligible world out there that's
so much easier easier for us to grasp if
we get away from this material world
Kant isn't doing that but he is saying
that listen if reason can raise problems
for us reason can also
resolve those problems why we're not
then concerned with nature or with given
objects at all but with mere
Concepts right be Bea that have their
origin their their origination solely in
our reason they come from reason and
with mere beings of thought so all of
the problems he says that arise from our
concepts of
them must be solved why so here we get
into something that shows a certain
normativity to reason itself something
that we're going to come up with you
know stronger formulation just a few
paragraphs later
reason can he says and must give a full
account Reon shaft of its procedure of
what it does so reason is this higher
faculty higher than sensibility or the
understanding which apply and pertain to
the experiential world the phenomenal
right reason goes beyond those and
reason has the capacity to actually look
at itself this is what critique in
consense actually is it's carried out
not by the understanding but by reason
so reason must give a full account of
its own procedure and here there's a
interesting
footnote he references ha plotner and
says if reason be a Criterion no concept
is which is inconceivable to human
reason can be possible
incomprehensibility has place in what is
act ual only incomprehensibility arrives
arises from the insufficiency of the
acquired ideas and con says it sounds
paradoxical but is otherwise not strange
to say that in nature there's much that
is incomprehensible but if we go higher
everything becomes conceivable why we're
no longer concerned with this
experiential realm where there's the
temptation of thinking that we're
actually getting to the things in
themselves we're not getting to the
things in themselves all we have are the
phenomena that we experience observe can
can theorize about and arrange in
certain ways so going on from this he's
going to say the psychological
cosmological and Theological ideas these
are nothing but pure concepts of Reason
we've already seen that before which
cannot be given in any experience right
you can't encounter limits to the
universe or non limits to the universe
and experience you can't experience the
immortality of the Soul you can't
experience the theological idea in any
way and so he says the questions which
reason asks us about them are put to us
not by the objects but by what he calls
the mere maxims of our reason and what
is the point of this he says that it is
for the sake of so there's a kind of
teleology here isn't there for the sake
of reason's own
satisfaction zels be right the
satisfaction of itself and this is kind
of an interesting thing to note it is
reason being active in that sense
producing a satisfaction for itself but
it is also a satisfaction of itself
about itself and its products is it not
so that single term there is actually
very productive
ambiguity so he's going to go on and say
all right the questions that that reason
asks must be capable of
satisfactory
answers which are provided by showing
that there principles which bring our
use of the understanding this is the
point of them into thorough now he got
three terms here thorough um agreement
should be agreement there
inite completeness full stendy kite
something that we've encountered over
and over and over again right in the
discussion of where we get these ideas
from and synthetical unity ineight so uh
these are three aspects we could say of
what it is that each of these ideas the
psychological cosmological or the
logical brings to the table for us or
rather how reason brings something for
its own satisfaction to the table right
and so he says they're they hold good of
experience only but of experience as a
whole right uh IM gansen not any one
single experience they are applied to
the
totality of all possible experience
and so he says although a whole absolute
whole of experience is impossible the
idea of a whole of cognition according
to principles in general must impart to
our knowledge A peculiar kind of unity
that of now notice this term that of a
system very important here to note Kant
is not looking just for
single principles he's looking for an
entire system that coheres within itself
that would have these these attributes
as well agreement
Unity uh we could say adequacy for fendy
completeness Perfection right being
brought as far as it can possibly go and
then he says something else really
interesting here without this system it
is nothing but peacework and cannot be
be used for its highest purpose Z end
goal purpose so we've already got a lot
of teleological language going on in
here right uh reason has to give an
account of its procedure reason has is
asking questions for the sake of Reason
satisfaction how does it find that well
through a agreement completeness
synthetical unity in a system which
itself is going to lead us to
understanding and perhaps being able to
fulfill the highest purpose of reason
and Kant is going to clarify here that
it is um the system of all purposes so
not only do we have to have a system of
these principles or pure ideas of
reason
we need to have a system of purposes all
purposes and he says I'm not just
referring here to the practical but to
the highest purpose of the speculative
use of reason now why make that
distinction there well within the realm
of the Practical use of reason right
you've already got purposes built in
there it makes perfect sense to ask
about purposes speculative reason or
pure reason maybe not so much so K want
wants to stress to us that it is both
aspects of reason that are being
involved here as having some sort of
purpose perhaps discernable certainly
thinkable imaginable Beyond it he also
wants to clarify as he so often does we
got to be careful here the
transcendental ideas Express The
Peculiar application of reason as a
principle of systematic unity and the
use of the understanding that's its
legitimate use but if we assume this
Unity of the mode of cognition to
pertain to the object of cognition what
it is that we're actually learning about
studying about making judgments about he
says if we regard that which is merely
regulative regulative in German as
constituative
constitutive right two important uh ways
of being regarded being looked at
regulative this is just the way things
have to go and we're not making any like
we could say existential claims
constituative we are saying okay we
understand how things work
causally uh what gives rise to to what
right and he says if we persuade
ourselves by means of these ideas we can
enlarge our cognition
transcendently and beyond all possible
experience then if if we do this we
suffer from a mere misunderstanding misf
andness in our estimate of the proper
application of our reason and its
principles and what else is going to
happen the dialectic of pure reason
right we suffer from a dialectic which
confuses the empirical use of reason and
sets reason at variance with itself if
reason in its use and in its extent is
not going to be
in
disharmony can't be falling into that
dialectic which is a possibility for us
but if we
can understand the way we're supposed to
look at and use reason then we can avoid
that and that's what the critique of
pure reason was intended to do and
that's what the prom at any future
metaphysics is doing in relation to
metaphysics